recently Bernardo Castro was interviewed
on the Artisan Tony Channel and had this
to say pertaining to being skeptical
about people who claimed to have
information but can't disclose it
because of an NDA or some other reason
when somebody starts by saying
you know I know a great many amazing
things but I really can't tell you my
immediate reaction in my mind is oh go
piss off if you really know amazing
things that you can't tell then you
don't you don't tell me that you know
them because you immediately get into a
discussion in which you'll be asked to
tell so when people do that I know
there's many things but I can't tell you
that my detector goes off scale
my alarm bells are all over the place
like this is somebody trying to create a
Nora of Exquisite knowledge to get
followers and buy his books or whatever
be careful when people come around
saying I know but I can't tell no be
suspicious of this because things that
are scams are presented exactly like
that I'm curious what do you think
comment and share